Red panda in name, it is not closely related to the giant panda,...
...but actually closer to the raccoon family.
He loves to eat bamboo...
...but won't turn down the occasional bird, insect or mammal for a snack.
Native to the Eastern Himalayas and Southwestern China,...
...red pandas live in trees and are nimble, agile climbers.
Their reddish brown fur and bushy tails...
...camouflage them in their habitat from predators like snow leopards.
Besides other animals, humans pose a major threat,...
...poaching and hunting them for their fur.
The forest that they live in are shrinking fast...
...and estimates say that their population has been cut in half...
...in the last 20 years.
This is the red panda.